[Musik]
sie sagt nicht nur hey jetzt sagt sie
auch antonia aus tirol klärt mallorca
den rücken jahre lang gehört die
schlagersängerin zur festen größe am
ballermann im bierkönig und im
oberbayern sorgte sie zwei bis dreimal
wöchentlich für stimmung
aber damit ist jetzt schluss eigentlich
wollte antonia 2020 ihr zwanzigsten
jubiläum mit zahlreichen auftritten
feiern
aber dann kam corona jetzt nach der
erneuten zwangsschließung der party
tempel auf malle steht für die 40
jährige fest der drops am ballermann ist
gelutscht und es wird nie wieder so wie
es einmal war ist aber auch gar nicht
schlimm
die österreicherinnen will jetzt einfach
in deutschland und österreich auftreten
und zwar mit einem ganz neuen konzept
kein glitzer kein dirndl
jetzt wird es rockig mitglieder rodmans
ja
[Musik]
und zu diesem thema spreche ich
natürlich auch direkt mit antonia aus
tirol
schön dass du dir heute abend zeit
genommen hast warum oder wie kam es denn
überhaupt zu dieser entscheidung jetzt
den ballermann tschüss zu sagen ich war
die entscheidung ja eigentlich schon ein
bisschen geplant wir hatten ja nach dem
20 jahren am ballermann schon vorher
gehabt aufzuhören
und ja die krone krise gab es jetzt kein
abschied ja sozusagen und ich hab jetzt
nachzudenken in dieser zeit wo man in
quarantäne war und habe mich dann
einfach entschieden das ganze dann etwas
früher zu beenden weil moment ja
dementsprechend kenne auch möglich sind
hier am ball am do hast ja auch gesagt
der ballermann wird deiner meinung nach
nie wieder so sein wie er mal war warum
denn
ja also man hat es ja schon gesehen die
ganzen auftritte jetzt nicht nur auch am
ballermann sondern in deutschland ist es
schwierig durch die durch diesen virus
und die menschen wenn sie feiern und
wenn sie bringt sind sie einfach nicht
ganz so unter kontrolle und verhalten
sich nicht so wie es den carola regeln
halten
dem entspricht und man weiß ja nicht wie
lange das ganze noch anhält uns die
regierung hat ihre entscheidung
getroffen und ebenso wie an denk ich mal
wird es eine veränderung geben am
ballermann
wir haben es gerade schon im beitrag
gesehen bei dir wird jetzt ein bisschen
rockiger erzählt uns ein bisschen mehr
darüber ja ein beitrag hab ich ja
gesehen dass auch ich auch auf mallorca
schon immer auch ein bisschen rock
angeschlagen habe es hat mir immer spaß
gemacht ich habe in meinem lifebook
haben immer schon dabei gehabt meine
fans haben das sogar immer positiv
gegenüber gestanden und habe ich gesagt
warum nicht und deswegen war jetzt schon
länger zeit die planung im mit meiner
band auf tour zu gehen
das neue album heißt rock schlager ist
alles echt eingespielt worden mit echten
instrumenten mit gitarre mit schlagzeug
und ja und das ganze geht jetzt auch nur
uns gleich sehr sehr viele auftritte
habe eben nicht nur im parlament sondern
in anderen ländern auch noch in
deutschland in österreich und so weiter
hat man irgendwann die entscheidung
getroffen um professionell weitermachen
zu können und das umsetzen können muss
man einfach mal abstriche machen und bis
jetzt am ballermann für mich nicht mehr
weiter